God has a little chat with him and he
says,
well,
W W,
why are you angry and and why?
Why are you upset?
And cain says,
and God says,
if you do well,
won't you be accepted?
And if you don't do well,
sin lies at your door and unto thee
shall be his desire.
And now shout rule over him.
Okay?
That's a very mangled translation I
would say,
so I'm going to take it apart.
So what God says is while you're angry
and you're upset,
it's like,
well,
what's your problem?
And then God tells kate if you did
things properly,
they would work out for you.
Well,
it's the last thing he wants to hear it
because what cain wants to believe is
that the reason he's not doing very well
is because there's no sense having any
faith in the logos.
The transcendent is,
is evil and aimed exactly against him,
and the entire social contract is
faulty.
That's what he wants to hear,
but that isn't what God says.
God says,
well,
wait a minute,
maybe you're doing something wrong.
Well,
that's maybe a worse message than
everything else is corrupt.
It's like you're having a problem
because you're just not everything you
could be.
Well,
and then God says something really nasty
and you can't tell from this lines.
I read a bunch of translations to try to
figure out exactly what it meant.
So this is what God tells kate.
He says,
you're in a room in a house and there's
something at the door,
and he uses a metaphor.
God uses a metaphor.
It's a sexually,
a lot aroused predatory cat,
and you invited in even invited.
Did you know that it has evil intent.
You invited in to meet with you,
right?
And you're.
It's,
it's union with you.
This,
this malevolent force,
this sexual union with you has produced
an offspring and that offspring is what
possesses you.
And so not only have you done something
wrong,
you've,
you've invited the spirit of wrongdoing
into your life and you've creatively
intermingled it with it voluntarily to
bring forth a monster of your own
creation.
So that's what God tells Kane.
So like,
look,
it's bad enough that God says,
you know,
you should get your act together because
maybe that's why things aren't going so
well for you before you criticize the
transcendent and the world and the
structure of being.
Maybe you're doing something wrong,
but it's worse than that.
He says,
not only are you doing something wrong,
you bloody well know you're doing
something wrong and you and you're doing
it creatively and with intent,
so not only are things not going well
for you,
but you've played a creative role in
producing that situation and so god
basically says,
I am taking zero responsibility for
rejecting your sacrifice.
It's all on you.
And so kane leaves and he's like,
seriously?
Not Happy with that response because he
wanted to hear Pat,
pat,
you're a victim of circumstance and
everything's conspiring against you.
And really being God,
I should get my act together and just
give you what you want.
Because obviously being God I'm wrong
and you're right.
Well that isn't what happens.
It's exactly the opposite of that.
It's completely on you.
That's the,
that's the judgment.
And so kane leaves and believe me,
he's,
he was wroth before it.
His countenance had fallen before,
but it's nothing like it is now.
And so he's hits the next stage and he
thinks,
okay,
I'm going to take my revenge.
What am I going to do?
I'm going to find the most innocent and
worthwhile thing that's favored of God
and I'm going to kill it.
And that's what he does.
And it doesn't matter.
That's his brother and able,
you know,
we're drawing the inference.
Ables done the right things.
Everyone likes them.
Everything's flourishing for Abel.
He's a good guy.
He's one of those people that you meet
that has everything.
And then you meet them and you wish you
could hate them,
but you can't because they're really
good people.
And then you're really hate them because
not only do they have everything,
but it appears that they deserve it.
And there's nothing that sort of sits in
your soul and rots it more than that
realization.
And so that's the situation with Cain.
And so thinks Cain talked with Abel,
his brother,
and it came to pass when they were in
the field that Cain rose up against
Abel,
his brother,
and slew him.
So that's so interesting because look,
look what happens to cane here.
So he's not doing well.
He's separated from the transcendent and
from society.
He's bitterly resentful and now he goes
out and kills the very thing that he
most wants to be.
So he destroys his own ideal,
right?
He just demolishes his own ideal.
That's how far his resentment has pushed
him.
And so he's,
he's done right?
But it doesn't matter because it enables
him to take revenge.
So he doesn't care.
It's like,
it's like the suicidal school shooter
that blows off his head at the end of
his mayhem.
It's like it doesn't matter to him.
It's part of the same art form.
And the Lord says unto Cain,
where is Abel?
And cain said,
I know.
I don't know,
am I my brother's keeper?
While that's a good question,
and that's why it's posed in the story,
because the answer that I supposed to be
yes.
And God says,
what have you done?
The Voice of your brother's blood cries
unto me from the ground.
That's actually the Motif that
Dostoevsky explorers,
I would say in crime and punishment
because what happens is that was calling
the coffee's cane for all intents and
purposes,
and he commits a murder,
but he gets away with it.
Well,
so he thinks so.
We thinks no one suspects him.
He buries the money.
He can't stand to touch the body.
He buries it in a in an abandoned lot,
and he's drawn there now and then to
look at where it is,
but he can't touch it because the money.
It's so funny because the money before
he kills the pawnbroker is not the same
as the money after he kills the pawn
broker.
And the risk only the before he kills
the pawnbroker is not the same as the
risk and the cough after he kills the
pole broker.
In fact,
they're not the same at all.
And so [inaudible] Nicole have is
tormented by God,
you could say,
but not from the external world.
He sets the crime up quite nicely.
It's that this,
this spirit against which transgressed
tortures him from within and there's no
escape from it,
and so eventually what happens in crime
and punishment is was called Nicole have
continues to manifest himself as guilty
in every possible way until he receives
the punishment that he desires because
it's the only way that he can set things
right.
He actually,
he actually,
he essentially turns himself in
eventually because he can't tolerate
what he's done so well.
So that's the idea.
The Voice of thy brother's blood cries
unto me from the ground.
It's guilt
and now you're cursed from the earth
which has opened her mouth to receive
your brother's blood from thy hand.
When you till the ground,
it will not henceforth yield to you its
strength and a fugitive and a vagabond
shall thou be in the earth.
You know?
And you might say,
well why does God not just straight and
dead?
And the answer to that perhaps is that
wouldn't be sufficient punishment.
That's what it looks like to me.
It's like what's the punishment?
You live with what you did.
Right?
And I don't want anybody taking you out
either because then you won't have to
live with what you did.
So that's the punishment.
And cain says,
under the Lord,
my punishment is greater than I can
bear.
It's like,
yeah,
behold you have driven me out this day
from the face of the earth and from thy
face shall I be here.
That's the same as what happens to Adam
in the garden of Eden.
Remember,
Adam hides from God and he has his
reasons.
And now cain is alienated from God.
There's no read,
there's no reconstructing that
relationship.
He's put himself by violating his
contract,
but say with the transcendent and also
with society and also with his own
spirit,
he's put himself outside the possibility
of redemption.
And that's why he says the punishment is
greater than I can bear.
There's no hope left,
right?
So he's in hell for all intents and
purposes.